[Musique]
chaque homme noir et avec l'
augmentation de 25 ans a mis les mains sur le
visage de la supernova causée par un super social
un juge de l'égalité pour tous mais je vais
lancer un programme d'affaires noires dans les
retombées des radiations de l'air sur mon bébé  disons que je suis
Manziel,
il nous a tout appris sur les embarquements
, les trucs sur le génocide, une autre façon de ramper cet
homicide, un homme, un homme, un peuple,
les médias ne nourrissant rien, rien pour le
mal était hors de proportion,
un cheval prend en charge va regarder la
victoire 4-1  le million de dollars doucement
parce que j'ai déjà trouvé un milliard de personnes dans
les maisons des femmes dans le bouclier
lisent le bétail se sent bien
partout où vous portez mes vieux garçons et le
rod chef casino fort
vivant dans
ce sont des représailles hardcore
[Musique]